in fact last night we saw a [ __ ]
documentary called athlete a mm-hm it's
good about Larry Nasser from USA
Gymnastics and God basically
finger-banged all those little girls I
shouldn't say it like that yeah what he
did that's what he did yeah yeah yeah
but it's like this girl you see a
documentary yeah you know the the
Olympic gymnastics Association had a
doctor named Larry Nasser and he was
number one you find out in the document
he didn't even get paid now he's a
[ __ ] singlet chaser dude you know how
difficult you know the coaches there are
so kind of mean well yeah like Marta
Russian baby the Russian yeah yeah the
Corollas the Crawleys they were like
there were Nadia Comaneci scotches so
they were just really celebrated tough
right coaches the stretch yeah yeah
and then if so you have all this
negativity and stress right and
emotional and ponytails and then they
had this guy this doctor who would give
these kids on the side
and he was nice it was a huge you know
red flag yeah right and then like you
know do leg massage and then all of a
sudden just jam yeah and how he decide
to defend it to he was like oh yeah this
is just you know coccyx manipulation
right nobody said yeah he won't do
things like he would talk about like the
the the pubic symphysis like things in a
really medically we use a lot of medical
jargon to defend what he was doing to
these girls
poor girls you know mean they shield
maybe their children their children but
then they go out there and they compete
and some of them become you know Olympic
gold gymnast right legends leaves us the
legends of our time right but you get
goes to show you that maybe you know
there was a thinking and I might have to
cut this out but there was a thinking
that we had a discussion is not the
molestation but the strict training in
my head I was like does the strict
training
right equate to Olympic gold but kilala
was like you can still be nice right and
still have love and still create
champions and I'm tending now to believe
that
well I my theory is that while
discipline hard work very regimented
old-school Soviet practices might work
you just don't have a longevity there
cuz there's only so much emotional abuse
and physical abuse and so much of your
body that you can run down so it's like
I always say these girls in the 90s most
athletes including myself we peak when
were 18 we're done our bodies are
already broken we've had every single
injury there is to have well now they're
being a little bit more you know
forgiving they're being a lot more
loving and supportive and know these you
have Dara Torres who was a swimmer in
her 35 still competing in the Olympics
and that was unheard of before yeah
imagine if comedy was like that it would
take the fun out of it
yeah I mean if I [ __ ] had a bad joke
I get in a Polish person to hit me with
a ruler no was a bad joke right you get
good fast I bet they're right yeah you
could get back but we all do that to
ourselves I think that polish person
just since iw hey guys we're going to
take a quick break to share one of our
favorite sponsors with you
[Music]
you guys I'm telling you right now
without blue apron I would have died in
quarantine we've had so many delicious
meals from blue apron
it delivers right to your door and it's
like it's you know guys it's like
restaurant quality food and it's food a
couple of times even the slept King Papa
made it mmm by following the orders I
don't chop